[Music]
it's true in your new movie snatch with
Goldie Hawn that by accident when you
were shooting your breasts expose and
that in fact we see Teddy in the movie
you show your breasts yeah true
oh yeah look at you my right to full nip
oh yeah fullness come on let's have them
look at Wow farther on the floor that
tells the movie right there I don't
think so a lot of people want to see
your nip well you know I'm sure a lot of
people will just see that that's easy
whatever I got in I guess it was flat
oh it was oh yeah I wrote it in oh I
didn't know yeah it's so unnecessary it
was such an unnecessary it switch eyes
and intuitive it's unnecessary and you
wrote it in because you did hey listen
there is a segment of the audience that
will go just to see now I just thought
it was funny
i I think that moments like really funny
I felt good to shoot it like it was kind
of empowering what is the reason that
your teddy falls out um in the movie
well I I was riding on the back of a
motorcycle with this guy I'm interested
in yes and then we we get off and he's
like are you okay mommy a walking room
and I'm like oh my god I'm fine I'm like
clearly very drunk but I was like I was
buzzed earlier but it's like gone and
he's like okay your tits out I'm like
well you know and what's the big deal
yeah and then it is out and this kind of
like you know this is a crazy question
but do you feel your right breast is
nicer than your left which did you
specifically say I exposed my right
breast
of course that's a great question the
right one is the star it is and then my
left ones like the runner-up is that
true is there a difference between them
a little tiny bit enough than I noticed
and somebody I'm dating would if I were
like which breast is bigger they've like
righty